it was a massacre that changed a country
[Music]
this uh is and will be one of new
zealand's darkest days
brenton tarrant opened fire at two
mosques in christchurch
killing 51 people it's just an animal
this guy's an animal the attack was the
deadliest mass shooting by a lone gunman
in new zealand's history how do you
plead guilty
but who is this extremist and what
happened
in those 19 minutes of terror
just after half past one in the
afternoon on march the 15th
2019 brenton tarrant starts live
streaming on
facebook from his car he's dressed in a
paramilitary style uniform
and armed with semi-automatic weapons
he is about to broadcast a terror attack
to the world tarrant drives towards
al-noor mosque
around 140 he enters the place of
worship
and opens fire indiscriminately shooting
men women and children
i actually heard the gun shots so you
can just like quite black banging like i
think
you can actually hear like you know
like something like that because he was
shooting bullets willy-nilly
it could have hit even him or anyone
they were just that much
milliseconds away from death when people
say these are traumatized of course they
are traumatized
to how can you not
be traumatized the attack lasts six
minutes
in that time he murders more than 40
people
at 1 47 armed police arrive on the scene
but terrance is gone he's already
started to drive towards
linwood islamic center this is where his
facebook live
cuts out i actually saw the gunman
driving you know where he
drove very fast i actually thought and
thought to myself
what a crazy man at 1 52 he arrives at
linwood
he shoots two people outside the mosque
before making his way inside we just
studied the prayer when
[Music]
i've never been to the war i've never
you know i've never used a weapon in my
life
but i knew this is not
normal and i saw that coward coming back
from the back of his car and
when i asked him who the hell are you
you start shooting at me and
i was screaming yelling at him come on
here because i didn't want him to come
inside the mosque because we had a lot
of people between
80 200 people was praying that day
and i want him to focus on me
but unfortunately he come inside and
shot a lot of brothers and sisters
and he drop his gun and run to his car
then i chased him to his car when he sat
on his car because we had a bit of
distance
he just looked at me and he just gave me
a finger i said i
killed all of you a 155 tarrant leaves
linwood mosque
seven people died at the scene
two more later in hospital at 157 his
car is seen by a police unit
they start to pursue him two minutes
later they stop the car
and arrest brenton tarrant his 19-minute
attack
stole 51 lives
tarrant published a 74-page hate-filled
manifesto prior to the murders
he emailed it to leading politicians
including the prime minister jacinda
ardern
just minutes before the shooting began
the people who were
the subject of this attack today new
zealand
is their home they should be safe here
the person who has perpetuated this
violent act against them
they have no place in new zealand
[Music]
society
more than 1400 miles away from christ
church
this is where brent and tarrant grew up
grafton is a city of around 19 000
people in new south wales australia
family and friends report remembering
him playing a lot of violent video games
when he was younger
and having trouble with women i i guess
you can't escape the fact that he was
from
this area when the media the media storm
arrived in grafton you know there was a
major sense of denial
um you know that we had nothing to do
with this and so why
tarnish us and our reputation as a
community
but i mean the fact was this is where
he's from tarrant was reportedly
immersed in online culture
he even posted his manifesto to the
internet before the attack
and encouraged users to watch his live
stream
it's such a borderless unpoliced area
that you can say whatever you like you
believe you're anonymous and largely
often you are and you never have to
prove you've got courage of your
conviction
he traveled to europe in 2016 and 2017
apparently visiting sites of crusader
battles
where christian armies fought islamic
forces
there's no way of profiling how
a radicalised terrorist is going to
radicalise and there's no way of
determining ahead of time exactly what
that trigger is going to be
later in 2017 he moved to new zealand
five hours south of christchurch this
house in dunedin
is likely where he planned his attack to
know that he
he might have been planning it for the
last you know year or so that he was
living next door
is is scary what do you know about your
neighbor
not a whole lot really he pretty much
kept to himself
but we'd pass them on the pathway every
now and again and he was always
really friendly kind of just makes you
wonder like who can you trust
from what we know of this fellow as he
stayed under the radar he's a quiet
quite disciplined individual that's gone
about
planning his attack
very carefully and very quietly my
understanding is that he came to new
zealand
from australia not planning to do
anything here
then he discovered actually new zealand
was a good place as any to have a go
he's very dangerous he's only planning
to do something once
he wants to establish himself as the
perpetrator of some dreadful act
that is going to give him the
opportunity
in the media space to articulate the
message that he's going
to do
brenton tarrant's attack did change new
zealand
but not in the way he wanted
the country was devastated by the
shootings
so much so that a ban on military-style
semi-automatic weapons was announced
just six
days after the attack our gun laws
will change now is the time for change
how do you feel
guilty or not guilty guilty
tarant pleaded guilty to 51 charges of
murder
40 charges of attempted murder and
admitted committing a terrorist act
it's illegal to show any of his facebook
live stream or publish his manifesto
new zealand is determined not to allow
his ideas to spread
but for survivors the memory of the
shootings
will be with them forever it's not
something you can
forget i don't think not a single day
i will not feel the depth of the agony
you know we went through that day
because crime
no i don't condone it but as a person
i'm prepared for a camera
straight up as a human being i will
forgive him if he's
guilty allah will punish him i'm just
human i'm no one to punish him